in this video we'll introduce the notion
of a Markov network we've seen before
that a conditional random field can be
written in a slightly different form we
seen before as essentially a product of
some factors and in the case of the
linear chain conditional random field
where we have unary potentials which
correspond to neural networks then these
factors would corresponds to would
correspond to these terms here we have
unary factors so the factors that
involve a single Y and pairwise factors
where this factor involves two adjacent
labels two y's so these would be the
unary factors this will be the pairwise
factors a very useful visualization of a
given conditional random field model is
known as the Markov network so it's a
network where the nodes are the random
variables in our model and edges take a
are constructing are added into the
network for based on a very specific
reason so the way we construct a Markov
network for a conditional random field
which we've written as a product of
factors is that first we would write all
of the different so we have a node for
each of the random variable in our
models in our case each of the labels if
we had a sequence of length 5 then we
have y 1 y 2 y 3 y 4 y 5 as well as a
node in this case for each of the input
vector X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 and X 5 so now
then we would add edges for between each
random variable that shares a factor in
the product of factor form for our
conditional random field for the linear
chain conditional random field then this
means that we would have and also for a
context size of radius 1 context window
grid is 1 then we'd have these diagonal
edges between a
label why and its input at its left so
then we have also an edge between each
label and the input at the same position
so those are the vertical edges here and
similarly we'd have edges diagonal edges
like this between hy and the label to
its right so those correspond to the
this factor here the factor between YK
and XK plus 1 so those were all the
unary factors and then for the pairwise
factors they would correspond to the
original edges here between H YK and its
neighbour YK plus 1 so what's useful
with the mark of network visualization
is that we can very easily identify
certain conditional dependencies between
the random variables of our model so for
instance the mark of network respects
what's known as the local Markov
property meaning that in the mark of
network a random variable is going to be
independent of all other random
variables that are not its Labour's
given its neighbors so for instance if
I'm considering this random variable its
neighbors in this graph would be this
one this one this one this one and this
one
well the mark of local Markov property
tells me that y3 is going to be
independent of Y 1 X 1 Y 5 and X 5 given
it's a mark of a blanket so its
neighbors y2 x2 x3 x4 and y4 ok so that
can be useful if we want to determine in
our model whether a certain random
variables are dependent on each other or
independent given other variables that
we might observe Sofia for some reason I
was observing so in the conditional
random field we always observe x1 all
the
the inputs so that's X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 and
X 5 so I've used a double circle 10 and
fight those notes that are observed but
imagine that also happen to observe in
this sequence y 2 and y 4 so maybe some
for some reason I actually have this
enformation well the local market
property will tell me that the
distribution over y 3 given these five
nodes actually does not depend on y 1 so
I can just ignore ignore it and compute
the conditional which is only going to
depend on these for these 5 nodes and
the particular the probability will of
course depend on the particular value of
y 3 for which I want to compute the
probability in fact we can say something
even a bit more general which is if I
have two nodes well then there are going
to be conditionally independent if all
the paths between the two nodes contain
at least one of the conditioning node so
one of the node that that I might be
observing and I'm conditioning over so
for instance if I'm wondering so imagine
in the conditional anything again at
when we use it while these observe all
the input now I imagine that I'm also
observing Y 3 and I want to know whether
Y 1 depends on Y 5 in this case there's
one path between y 1 and Wi-Fi so it's
this path actually I could there are
other paths I could go like this so
there's more than one path I could go
like this and like that and so on
well it turns out in this case we can
easily see that each path between y 1
and Wi-Fi actually contains one of the
note I'm conditioning on that is it
either contains one of the inputs so
each path that goes through an X node
would be blocked by by the X know that's
observed that I'm conditioning on and if
I'm assuming I'm also observing this
well then any node that stays up like
this and goes through y3
is going to contain conditioning notes
so it's going to be blocked in a sense
and so for that reason we could say that
y1 and Wi-Fi is is independent
conditionally independent given x1 up to
X 5 and y3 so that's a useful property
of the mark up network it allows us to
identify a lot of conditional
independencies very easily another thing
that's important to understand about
conditional random fields is that
they're known as undirected graphical
models to be distinguished from directed
graphical models like a hidden Markov
networks and Bayesian networks in
general and so what this means is that
when I write it in the form of a product
of factors well all of the factors so
I'm giving an example here where we are
conditional random field with a with no
context window or contact window of size
1 that only contains the input at the
current position so in this case I only
have can think of this as only
containing two types of factors well in
this case in the in the conditional
random field these factors only need to
be non-negative so they need to be
greater or equal to zero that's the only
requirement that I have in an undirected
graphical model is that when I write it
as a product of the factors well the
factors themselves they only need to be
such that there are always greater and
equal than zero so that's to be
contrasted with a hidden Markov model so
if we visualize it as a Bayesian network
that is a network where the nodes are
the random variables and the edges are
now directed well each edge in this case
corresponds to a conditional probability
in the model that's a property of a
Bayesian network in this case for a
hidden Markov model the this arrow here
would correspond to the conditional
would illustrate that
with corresponding conditional
probability of y2 given y1 and also X to
the arrow from y2 2 x2 would correspond
to the conditional probability of x2
given y2 so the arrows what are they are
saying essentially is that in the
genitive story behind the model y2 was
generated based on y1 only and then x2
was generated based on y2 only so
because now if you write in factored
form then all the factors will
correspond to these probability
distributions and it means that we do
satisfy the fact that these because
their probability distributions they're
going to be greater and equal than 0
however in a director graphical model
the factors also need to sum to one with
respect to one of the arguments here so
for instance this factor would sum to 1
with respect to X K because it's a
conditional probability so this
distribution over X K and similarly this
factor between pairs of labels with
something 1 with respect to YK plus 1
because it's a conditional distribution
over YK plus 1 ok so that's an important
distinction between a directed graphical
model like an hmm and a conditional
random field which is an undirected
graphical model so now the edges do not
correspond to conditional distributions
they just come on to factors or their
associated to factor with factors or
combated compatibility function we just
express a preference for the values that
can take each of the random variable in
the factor of compatibility function and
in particular if we were to try to
identify conditional independencies in
the directed graphical model and so from
the Bayesian network it would actually
be more complicated so there is the D
separation rule which I won't explain
here but you can find in most textbook
in the graphical on graphical models
which requires a bit more complicated
rule than just looking at the path
between the variable
and identifying whether under each fad
between the random variables there is at
least one node which correspond to a
conditional know what there's a slightly
more complicated rule due to the fact
that the edges between the nodes are are
directed and correspond to normalized
factors to conditional distributions all
right so that code covers Markov
networks and as well as the distinction
between undirected and directed
graphical models